foreign
dad was my first deployment in Iraq we
were doing night raids so every night
we'd go out and you know capture people
just the idea of like night after night
going into people's houses and like
occasionally waking them up with your
hand over their face and taking them out
I think my kids would be like holy
that was cool that's way cooler than
mine then I would follow up with how
many people themselves from the
fear you as a new guy would put on
gloves and have to search the the poopy
pants oh so find anything good when you
go home and you're like taking off poop
gloves you have to fly back with poopy
gloves no I take them off there's a
choice I made
hahaha